and we are live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidra your SciFi TV and move your
channel how are we Mah Hard Rock and
Amigos doing well doing quite Welling
good very well Sarah is in with us car
in with us it's morning graer
is uh Harris is with
used is with us how are we everybody in
the chat as well right so
you put the Christmas hat on again Matt
there will be question it's
Christmas it's Christmas time yeah it is
we were just talking about Harris
sorry the more hat the
merrier Bob how you doing I bought I got
given this hat as a birthday present for
streaming when I played
RuneScape and now I don't stream
RuneScape so I'm GNA wear it here good
fair enough fair enough can't argue with
that right today we are doing a little
bit of a um a whatif video I suppose or
a fantasy fantasy Stargate video and
we're gonna have a chat about what we
think sort of I suppose the political
situation of the Galaxy is is that a
fair way of saying it
yeah today in Stargate so um we've got a
few points we're going to go through and
we're really thinking about the villains
and the the allies and the good guys and
the bad guys sort of thing so guys get
into the comments as well and tell us
what you think as we're going along but
we are GNA
start by talking about the gold world
and I've just would said what about the
gold but we'll whatever that means to
you so first of all just basically
opening thoughts before we get into it
anything well I mean I guess uh
for me the go old
we I'm just wondering how many uh more
um I don't know species of gold is
floating around out there that we never
really found you know or if there's you
know the old you know pick somebody else
other than um
humans you know to to try to grasp power
I mean is there another race out there
that we haven't stumbled cross where
they go old or thriving but kind of
hiding you know I see I mean like how
they wanted to jump into the back what
were those um things that the KNX had
that they were trying to the gold or
trying to capture because they were
invisible yeah oh yes those things or
are they in some like sort of IND
dimensional beings or are they some sort
of you know Mirror Universe you know
where they're growing their power before
they come back and just you
know come back to the mil away for you
just have that with you all the
time same
thing I'm doing a Mirror Universe I'm
trying think G try to do a Mirror
Universe video tomorrow where I
basically interview myself so it's there
already see how that goes um I always
like the um the idea so jumping on the
back of what st's just said we had the
unus we had the
humans Anubis kind of already tried to
do this by genetically engineering one
but what if
what if the GU got into an
ancient yeah um it would have to be in a
physical form so would it be like an
alteran but there are there are physical
like in my head there are still physical
ancients about because some of them some
of them wouldn't have ascended not an
ascended being an ancient yeah yeah that
not necessarily the Ancients that we
know like that that group because
obviously there's going to be off shoes
like we already had the oray offshoot
but there must be others ancient
communities or descendants of the
Ancients
with physiology that's very similar to
the Ancients before they ascended and
maybe they just don't want to ascend so
they haven't what if a goward got into
them what if the go world rocked up to I
mean we're going to talk about the aen
later we're going to talk about um uh oh
crap I forgot the name of
the the the race that we really Advanced
but then NIS batted him the Tolan the
Tolen what if they got into the Tolen or
something that I mean take over a very
Advanced race and the you know the the
gold got into sort of that because at
the end of that where we know the gold W
are from when sg1 ended we know there's
a bunch of them on
Earth Elon Musk maybe um would explain a
few things um we know the system Lords
gone and we know they're hiding all over
the place
so Harris I mean is it fair to say
they're going to be desperately trying
to reconsolidate power reconsolidate
power yeah yeah and I mean they could be
doing that in a a slew of different ways
uh my brain was going in a dozen
different places Mr add surprise
um just just I I'll hop right back on
that idea but just this isn't part of it
at all but
there's time travel in
Stargate what is keeping the G from
using time travel and going back and
actually putting themselves inside of
any ancients way back
when suppose so I don't know that I mean
that's just a good way I think for them
to be doing something extra creepy or
like it's kind like some sort of
Doomsday scenario if all this goes wrong
we'll still have the backup plan of the
ancient hiding
someplace almost like he who remains in
Loki but Gold version you know uh just
that that was just a a thought out of
nowhere but um I think they would be
reconsolidating their power they'd be
trying to put themselves in the asan the
Tolen I mean the tokra might be trying
to take out the gold in their own way so
I don't know exactly how they would play
into what the ghoul themselves
specifically are doing they would have
play in somewhere there's not many toer
left is
there not a whole bunch but
[Music]
numbers
think we got ask sort of where's the to
would they be our friends or was it just
because they were a friend of our you
know the friend of your friend is no the
enemy of your enemy is your friend so
would they still be now that the enemy
is pretty much gone because we didn't
have a very good relationship we did we
but actually that numbers are dwindling
and if we continue to strengthen our
relationship with the Jafar the toker
wouldn't like that either
so kind of lose that enemy of your enemy
kind of thing yeah no one's happy in the
Galaxy you know just it's just just we
we got rid of the
um the go old so to speak and it just
that vacuum just always gets you know
filled with somebody else well we'll
talk about the Lucian Alliance in a bit
because that's a
big I think for 100% that the the go w
at least some sort of offshoot is
planning a return because looking at the
history of the go I'm writing a video at
the moment um on a particular go and I'm
doing a little bit of research on it and
it's quite interesting so the videos are
going to be about Anubis um but
the before the events of
sg1 Anubis was essentially like
just what's a good comparison
um that that that guy in so car Lair
he's a go W he's got one eye he was
basically one of them but this this go
called a pep or apep whatever whatever
you want to call
it um and he eventually killed AP blah
blah
blah and then raah came along and
started a war which lasted for 300
years and then and then banished and
then banished to
nubus in the grand scheme of things
everything that's happened between when
the T first like went through the gate
and then defeated all the the system
laws was only in the span of what 30
years but that that battle the original
battle with Anubis was 300 years of
Civil War they're not
impatient they will definitely they will
definitely regroup and they will
definitely try to re recoup their
power since the tokra and the gold have
just diminished numbers generally right
now do you think that they would in I
don't it's far-fetched but would they
possibly put their differences as de
side to reconsolidate power in the
Galaxy maybe I don't know I can't really
see them working together but also if
they're both pissed off at everybody
else enough
maybe enemy my enemy the numbers I don't
think has diminished as the as the tokra
the only reason the tokra numbers as
diminished as they are is because the
original Queen that spawned all of the
tokra which genetic memory and
predisposition to basically not be a
[__] uh she's dead
the other go wood Queens yeah they still
exist at least some of them we saw in
episodes Lakes full of Symbiotes jumping
out of the water in it like and that's
on exactly on the home planet where
where they where they naturally um are
born there's going to be hundreds
thousands millions of them in
there or or think about you know if you
reboot the franchise with the gold like
you know you do it but you treat it like
flipper
no you know it's just they scuba down or
all little no okay I wouldn't scuba dive
in that
Lake did you got the score what the
movie right yeah the big ass teeth what
are they and
they doing well against today and I
um no strip meat off bones in seconds in
the piranhas panas
panas like
thator I
was my brain generally tries to tune you
out Matt best best it can if while we
your default is shut up Matt isn't
it where's the button where's the
button's beautiful
beautiful not quite seamless but yeah
um I I think when when starget comes
back it's logical that the gold are
gonna be in it in some
way how how much though do you think
it's a good idea to sort of bring them
back because they're the original
antagonists it's a good way to start a
new series rather because I always think
any new series it's got to start off
pretty L it's got to have somewhere to
go if you know what I mean it can't just
start off up here you it's got to it's
got to build up something so is it a
good idea to start with the gold because
they're a good grounded villain that we
know about and actually it just is
logical that they're still about and
like you said Matt they desperately want
their power
back the amount of time between when
Stargate Universe ended and now is
basically as long as when the T first
entered the Stargate to when they defeat
the system Lord so they've had enough
time to
recoup they could easily they could
easily be um a coalition of like of new
system Lords that have just been hiding
in the shadows maybe they're in a
different galaxy maybe they just just
went somewhere else to recoup and that's
why no one's known about him for the
last 13 years and then they an Andromeda
yeah yeah then they come to exact
Revenge upon upon those pesky
to I would have get away with it too it
wasn't few
bisc um Ralph I've explain this to you
before and I'm not explaining it to you
again this is the last time system Lords
the system Lords are gone not all of the
go World there are go World on Earth the
system Lords are gone I'm not saying it
again not to mention the entire un's
home world that is also the gold home
world that we were talking about
earlier yeah exactly so I was always
surprised that we never saw more una SC
because that was their chosen host for
so long yes humans were easier to repair
but surely we'd see a couple just like
sitting around there was that one in
Thor's hammer obviously but well I'm I'm
still convinced that they're going to
the if if the unises are progressing
into species whether they're 20 years
along with a little bit of help from
everybody else in the Galaxy or not
they're not gonna be like that advanced
if they're biting their time and want to
play the long game the unas are the
perfect place to do that just pop in an
unus or two and keep going plot twist
chucker was a go old the entire
time rush was Rush is a
go explain a lot wouldn't
it for a while that he's at Gold I think
he
is he he's got the Tendencies and he is
a he could totally be a tokra someone
that's like kind of good but like just
pissy all the time you know he kind of
fits that mold already yeah well the
arrogance
intelligence check the only thing that
blows that theory out of the water is
the fact that Sam Carter has met rush
and hasn't detected naor in his blood oh
you and your logic damn it that's the
only thing that that that makes it damn
it
maybe look if the goold are trying to
hide right they are gonna have and
remembering they're quite bright they
will have to think of ways to hide so
maybe one of the things they would do is
sort of like an anti with like we have a
CO jab it just like think and it makes
your arm Go funny for a couple of days
but you know then you're all right they
have to sit down for 10 minutes and be
monitored yeah sit down and then nobody
watches you so you have to sit down I'm
sitting down I'll be here for 10 minutes
and as soon as they turn around just get
a walk out that's what I did three times
I got um a nice invite asking me if I'd
like to have a new one another shot this
year and I've I've respectfully said I'm
all
right um I've had it like nine times now
and I'm always fine so I just stop
testing that's the way to that's the way
to get past covid stop testing yourself
when you get
poorly that's a that's um a health
Minister from the
UK that's a health disclaimer do not
listen to me um but anyway yeah
so so do we agree then go world will
probably be in the new series because
it's logical um and it is probably a
good place to start and then it gives
them something to build up from and and
the go are there they're going to be
there or thereabout
somewhere um you mentioned a great place
to start I've got a really good idea
about you know if they if uh Stargate
picks back up where they kind of left
off with the sg1 I've got a the perfect
opening scene it starts back up with uh
Daniel Jackson uh giving his um the Old
Kingdom in the fourth dasty lecture
you know but it's updated for Stargate
since you know if the you know it's
become public knowledge then he can give
his lecture without all of the uh the
booing and the hissing and all of the um
the condensation that he got the first
time around and it would be it'd be good
because he of all the characters that
boy needs some Vindication you know I
mean he's been I mean it's just and it'd
be nice if Bill NY could be in the front
damn row you know what I mean if just
and maybe Neil deg grass
Tyson and then the same thing mirror the
opening scene of the movie the first
time we yeah yeah but but it's you know
now now there's disclosure right and
then it's like oh yeah that's what
you've been doing for the last 20 years
yeah okay oh you're not a that's
actually brilliant that is
brilliant yeah I I I I do have some
powerful shower
thoughts
best place to have
him know you're watching the the episode
of um I guess is a Stargate Atlantis
When U Rodney was back on Earth and
there was a the mad scientist that
stolen his work or whatever and they the
bridge it was the the bridge technology
that winai bridge we know and had nil
degrass Tyson and Dill NY in the episode
I thought well you know if I can do the
same thing you know what what what what
are those two going to say when uh
Rodney's papers all come out and it was
yeah he was right and well what about
Daniel Jackson I mean if anybody needs
to be Vindicated it should be Daniel
Jackson because he has you know just
been bullied in the archaeology
Community all this time and I thought
that would be an awesome way to open the
next next series is mimic the the first
open questions from the audience and
someone will go Dr Jackson what was it
like to die three times
actually I died four
times I want that guy from Ancient
Aliens to be sat in the front going
great who told
you I'm not saying it was aliens but
actually he is he's saying it was
aliens lopis or whatever his name was I
want him in the front with a big hair
and giant giant hair um that would be
awesome um but yeah no no that's that's
that's how they should open the that's
how they should open the first series so
so since you know Brad go tell Brad yeah
no I mean him like that now yeah yeah
yeah
yeah I'll take a writing credit um right
next on my who follows me on Twitter now
maybe I should you can go and tell him
then I'm I'm being careful because I I
got I went through a phase though I was
messaging a lot and I was just like I me
I've messaged him
once I've messaged him once and I'm not
doing it
again
I want him to continue following me yeah
I don't want him to I don't want to
annoy him right so the next one what are
going to be the biggest threats in the
galaxy and the my you know my first
thought when I thought about this
question was probably us it's probably a
t generally speaking on Earth anyway if
we use the Earth as an example
everywhere we go we destroy everything
we can and we take over everything and
we we exploit it but if it's not us or
what are the biggest threats to us in
the Galaxy today um and I want to throw
out there for one the a Shen just just
just as as a as a as a starter for
starter for six or whatever the saying
is what are you guys they're the most
they're the most patient race we ever
saw in
Stargate they are going to be pissed
that the first gate address that we gave
them was a black hole that would have
killed quite a few of them I reckon they
would have Dev with a lot of resources
to close that gate they would have
probably their their power at that time
would have been well it was it was
greatly diminished but they're very
patient so they would have slowly been
building up and up and up I can see them
coming
back boring guy his name was boring
wasn't it yeah his name was boring
boring there was always plans for a
third episode that they never got round
to Brad said there there were plans with
him ji for a third episode but they just
ever got Ry so there is a there is a
trilogy there
potentially how about you what what do
you guys think aen someone
else I think at some point time you have
to address this Shen you know it's I
mean we didn't spend there weren't any
episodes on you know their absolute
destruction I mean I think the Shen
probably had a better time of it in the
end than the Janai you know yeah well
the J's still kicking yeah but I think
the shin would be more
kicker oh yeah they're they're closer to
home I mean yeah in in ter you we don't
doubt that the the Janai still around
even though they had some issues I think
the Ain had less issues so I don't I
think they would still be you know out
and about do n Ain thing you know J I I
think would would have had plenty of
opportunity to recoup and Rise the power
in the interim
because if Atlantis is now on Earth and
let's assume it stayed there Pegasus is
now on
man they they're only like 60 years
behind us where they were when we first
met them like culturally they're only 60
years
behind I I could see them like easily
recouping and like just exploring
Pegasus a bit more getting a little bit
like of better technology and maybe
they've even surpassed what we were so
instead of instead of being 60 years
behind maybe they're now like 20 years
ahead and I mean we've got the
advantages we've got the asard core but
where we
were at the beginning kind of thing well
they could even lean into sci-fi and use
like maybe they're doing a different
type of Technology maybe they're not
doing uh the things that we did maybe
they're they're figuring out a different
way of doing it like the the Lans did
back in the day or so on so forth any
other these other
species lean under the side I
have so like the Lans had a nice
steampunk feel and then they went
actually crystals we love crystals
something yeah Crystal I mean there were
a few species that we only saw like once
like the beetle the transforming Beetle
faed dudes or whatever they
were the2 maybe have reappeared now as
well um but no those things they were
they were Brown and they were they were
shape-shifting um Yeah Yeah from epod
thing so one of the the the perceivable
threat I think would be it'd be like I
guess more political um but it would end
up not being political obviously because
it might start a Galactic Civil War kind
of thing but would the Knox consider us
the fifth race would they would they
agree with what the Asgard did by
literally like kind of essentially
making us the fifth race where the Knox
say no no no these were children like we
told them they were a couple weeks ago
maybe a year or two ago they're not
ready for this and they're going to
destroy our galaxy would they possibly I
know they're a peaceful group but would
they maybe change their tune a little
bit to keep peace in the Galaxy that's
an interesting thought because what the
Knox have no proof that the Asgard said
it like they literally said you are the
fifth race and then five minutes later
killed themselves so like for all
intents and purposes like the only
surviving um members of
we didn't agree to that so we said
there's like a villain for the new
series would maybe be like a Thanos type
villain that doesn't think it's doing
wrong maybe it's nox we we I mean we
said evil Ewoks obviously fings is our
favorite but maybe it's the nox maybe
the nox are just like these children
cannot have this it's like it's like a
five-year-old running around with a
shotgun uhhuh but they're doing it under
the guys of pacifism the guys of like oh
we're just bringing peace back to the
Galaxy taking out
people okay so I don't know it's the the
Knox you know like you like uh you were
saying Harris is is you know hyper
pacifist they didn't do jack [__] about
the gold the gold was just absolutely
evil so if they could stand around and
oh it's just the gold taking over the
Galaxy and enslaving billions of people
then I don't think they'd have any
trouble with you you know us running
around the world trying to do the
world but if it looks like we just took
out the ghoul and if the Knox don't know
that we were given all that technology
by the Asgard it almost looks like we
took it and stole it and took them out
as a species as well so they might be
coming into it with a different thought
process it might not be though that they
are then violent towards us or start a
war with us they might just be doing
something that like removes our
technology they don't hurt us but they
put us back in our pen sort of
thing be trying to pacify us you know be
honest if they're going to start a new
series they need to severely limit the
the power that the to have because
otherwise we're not a threat there's no
threat big
enough in my eyes we were so powerful by
the end of sg1 that anything that comes
our way they could basically just swap
them away like flies at this
point well we've got weapons that can
our capabilities that's why my example
for thetion Alliance aren't a threat
because they've only got gold ships and
the Asgard beam energy weapons can cut
through those Shields like butter you
know they're not a threat the Del Lucian
Lions can have a 100 warships and we can
have one 304 and we can pretty much like
just going to take you out one at a time
pretty much um so what if the Los
Alliance teams up with the Asian maybe
the Tolen whoever whoever whoever they
they start their own little
Alliance what against the T but what if
they get a hold of the veneer and the
veneer didn't necessarily love us so
what if the veneer join them and they
get Asgard level power to a degree maybe
not the same type of Asgard power that
we have but pretty damn close oh yeah I
mean what yeah in in in it seems like in
Harris's scenario the T becom threat
what if the Knox are still doing their
thing making us P pacifying us the T and
then the alliance is going on and doing
their thing and they end up being way
ahead of us technologically and we're
like
screwed I don't know I'm just
naking no I I think that's more like
again we think about logic aren't we
logical how have turned up would the
rest of the Galaxy just automatically
trust us we've turned up and all of a
sudden we've got Starships we've got
Asgard beam technology they don't a lot
of the people that know what's from [__]
every single world we have showed up on
whether for right wrong or indifferent
we have completely turned upside down so
that's the truth oh my Lord why are we
always a threat
history because we always
are I mean you could look at it
like we in America for ex in America
they have an election every four years
so they would have gone through what
like four different Presidents by
now yeah that's true their political
climate might be drastically different
to what it was back in the Heyday of the
SGC maybe the SGC is no longer operating
because it was deemed too expensive
maybe everything's been put into storage
maybe
maybe the people in power have just
decided actually we're not going to go
in and just get technology to make um
Earth better we're going to go in and
try and subate other people we're going
to you know we're going we're going to
be the oppressors
now race already has a history with
slavery like it's not that far out like
that that far out the Realms of
possibility that about the politics in a
minute aren't we shut up and we're gonna
talk about the Earth politics in a
minute so we'll come back to that
because it's a good point I mean like
you said you know we actually have
religions built around slavery yeah
coming back to it we'll come back to it
okay okay let me let me in a way that
makes sense at some
point shut up everybody shut
up just say what you like anyway um I
like that though the Lucian Alliance
found the fing Tech because they the
Lucian Alliance have shown themselves to
be like the cus of the Galaxy they will
they just absorb technology apparently
are the Lucian coition of criminals
isn't it so they're just going to steal
whatever they can to get up the
power does it make sense that they're
the biggest threat to us they were at
the end of or the start of
SGU say be a contender a massive
Contender
forend that's gonna be a contender
baby
um they've got
numbers
yeah and if they're making alliances
yeah and they've got power through
intimidation and fear as well like the
did they're not subjugating people with
like glowing eyes but they've got like
Manpower and guns because they're
criminals it's like it's like a the
mafia essentially whereas the go old
were
more I don't
know the the go were more like gangas
Khan and these are like the
Mafia the luian alliance at the space
they're the Huts from Star Wars
essentially just a little less bad to
look at less slimy yeah well the thing
is the Lucian Alliance as well they're
going to rock up and they're basically
all these cities and town all these PE
humans that have spread all over the
universe and they're going to basically
turn up and go do you want resources do
you want this do you want that and then
it's only later you go right now here's
the price because it's exactly what the
mafew did I mean really in a similar
sort of way they you know they they prop
up the leaders with money and gifts and
technology and then they then there's a
price afterwards um I mean as as we're
talking about what ifs and stuff what if
the Lucian Alliance were to flead their
case to the tokra and and get the
remaining tokra on their side kind of
deal and kind of have them propped up
from there I I just think that it's a
very sensible idea to consider that a
lot
of species out there would consider the
T the new
threat there would be an alliance
against us and that could be the new
threat but is it a bit
boring it's a bit it's not like it
hasn't been done before but it I guess
it'd be the difference with this is we
would be convincing everybody hey we're
we're the good guys we're like trying to
fight back and protect ourselves but we
are the good guys we're not like trying
to screw everybody over even though we
tend to one way or another uh history
does sort of
suggest so it's not like we're trying to
be the evil empire this time around like
we typically are you know or or any
sci-fi kind of thing where it's like the
in Empire and Foundation or or Star Wars
St whatever you know like it's always
that one kind of mass group trying to
take over as much as possible that's not
what we're
doing O'Neal and Hammond in that one
episode when O'Neal wants
to some of us been captured or something
Anil wants to go back in with Armed
Forces basically force them to do and
Hammond said going we don't do that and
then Neil said since
when we try to force our ideals on
others when did that happen and it is
true yeah we do so best intentions
what's what's they say about the the pav
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions yeah we could go out there
with loads and loads of really good
intentions and screw everyone up so we
probably is best to just keep it simple
stup stupid yeah we don't do that very
well who are the most likely or what are
the most likely allies and I'm going to
again I'll throw out the first one the
jaffan
nation is that prob
maybe there I feel like they're either a
bigger Ally or biggest threat I feel
like they're the
Klingons to me they so easily become the
biggest threat um because they War They
isn't their whole thing like
fighting it's all they've known for the
last
Millennial how long have they been
enslaved by the gold remember about the
fre jaar is they are now relying on
tronin and they're only getting that
from us that's a good point too
so I don't see them I don't see them
ever breaking that
pact little coup every now and then I
think but
holy they will be our
allies what if they become the new
system what if they what if there's some
sort of crazy Jaa sect that has some
sort of secret you know gold Queen
hidden in some dark basement on some
dark planet and all of a sudden hey
we're really going to screw [__] up
let's go get put things in our heads and
then all of a sudden there's jofa 2.0
running around as the system Lords then
the Frog like well how did we let this
happen maybe we should talk to the tar
well there's already political turmoil
within the Javan Nation so what if
I mean not everybody was on board with
tronin anyway so what if there's like a
subsect of jafa that are like we never
putting that weird blue drug in our body
and we're we're not shortening our
lifespans and our ability to do the
things that we're able to do what if
we're not going to be a go old of course
but let's keep them inside of us and if
we do that it allows us to be the most
ageless species in the galaxy and allows
us to be kind of like the head honchos
the the wiser group of the folk you know
uh
if we're talking about logic though as
well do we really think the Jaffer are
going to allow us to control them with
tronin
after Generations being controlled by
the know the gold world that I thought
would have happened between now and then
say either we want to be able to
manufacture our own tronin or maybe
that's what causes up a bit of you know
bit tension between the two
Nations they're not going to like it
they if we're the only that can produce
it they're not gonna
like there's
got I think you know at some point in
time you know once the jafa you know are
allowed and the free Jafar are allowed
to pursue education and Technology and
Engineering I'm sure they will come up
with something on their own just uh so
they they're not dependent on us because
we're I mean it's just not you know the
relationship between the jafa and us for
their tronin or whatever it's like you
know humans have a big Target on their
back from everybody else and maybe they
are wanting to
um come up with a solution for them in
case things go bad for the tar e you
know what I mean and you know we there's
just there's a lot of anger coming our
way from everybody else and maybe Jai
really want to be independent to be
truly independent they got to get away
from Earth made
Trona yeah we've spanked a lot of
Bottoms in the Galaxy there's a lot of
people with sore bottoms that going to
be very
angry it does seem that on a week basis
every everywhere sg1 went somebody got
into trouble um and it was it was like
like every night in a Thursday night for
like 10 years um that happened it's
crazy
um is it the Jaffer that are the most
likely though to be our allies or are
there other or or or would we say the
KNX maybe if they maybe take us under
the wing that our version of the Vulcans
from you know like Star Trek may I think
too isolationist to become our um become
our true
allies just
because every interaction we've ever had
with them they've basically just been
dismissing dismissive of of of thear
they're just like you're too young we
honestly we don't care we're gonna go
sit in the tree yeah
right wor Jafar if you think about it
owe not not not literally ow us like
they're not in our in our debt or
anything like that because we didn't do
it that but they they owe a lot of their
all of their freedom essentially to the
T and their way of life now is a direct
result of what the T did so I don't
think only 13 14 years later they would
have then turned around and said
actually cheers for killing the GU that
have been enslaving us for thousands of
years she has for given us like
political power and on the galactic
table but now we don't we don't want to
be involved I can't see that
happening I could see it to be I could
see that if all you need is a new leader
to come in and to sort of go um we need
to stand on our own two feet and like
not not me become like an enemy but to
try and separate themselves from us
Garett tried doing that and the go and
the
Jafar basically said no
like well I think they relying us a lot
anyway because I mean the nation is
still new isn't it there're still
there's practical things that and
Technology they would want from us and
stuff and so yeah I think they're
probably going to be our closest Ally
and we've got people like T that would
probably be very an influential leader
there who's obviously always going to be
loyal to the T I mean if br's not like
prime minister or president or something
of the Jaa Nation at this point he
should
be yeah go check out my last video it
was quality it's beautiful didn't do it
for you know first chapter brought
something up a minute ago he said a
matth vill and Knox like Mor Ari maybe
would be great I I I do like the Knox
for being this pacifist kind of group of
people this entire culture of of
pacifism but that's boring as hell like
they can't be just utopian all the time
and not every single KNX ever born would
be let's go hug trees and turn invisible
and hide away from people like the they
there'd be a messed up KNX or two along
the way I don't think that's like I I I
don't think that would be disrespecting
what we've seen already and I don't
think that would be taking away from the
rest of the the species as
well evil Knox would be cool evil lot of
these guys would be cool my argument
with the fings I like you know that one
episode when the um gold planted that
was it a suicide flower or something I
forget and but it was a ferling um it
was a ferling city and it was like any
anyone was welcome and um and but then
the go planted some plant that made
everyone go nuts it was a yeah SE that
made everyone go crazy yeah yeah so I
mean at some point I could I can
completely believe that the um the fings
would have gone you know what [__]
them let's let's go crazy on these asses
they they literally made us all go
suicidal and tried to kill each other
let I think that maybe we should sort
these go World out um it's it's logical
makes sense it would I think it's
possible go you like you got a
thought no I was just reading the uh
chat and the and Ken Southern brought up
Buddhist Warriors and it was like you
know I mean the it does kind of remind
me of the jafa you know with you know
they did have this philosophy about him
and they were just really efficient
Killers you know and so I was just I
don't know I was pondering that
it makes sense that actually when a um
even a peaceful being or peaceful
species if they feel they're in the
right can become very dangerous it's
like elves and the Lord of the Rings and
stuff it's like they're trying to be as
as great for the the the trees and the
nature around them as possible so when
they go and kill somebody they're going
to do it as quickly and efficiently as
possible and put them back into the
nature put them back into the world let
them decompose to help the trees grow
and all that kind of stuff they might be
like good reason for it and do it in
like a as humanely and and quickly and
safely as a way I mean once you get over
legal's you know blowing blonde hair The
Elves and uh Lord of the
Rings really dangerous I mean they were
Al they were um you know a warrior
Society I mean they had vast armies they
really had amazing battle skills they
were
I mean you know they were fighting a lot
I mean they but most people don't
associate their violent
nature to what you read in the books or
whatever but if you really look at what
they were doing man don't piss off an
elf what what if the Pegasus Asgard came
back what is what if the Pegasus Asgard
yeah came back to the Milky Way galaxy
and when
T all of that
all of that you know technology it's
ours by
right you know okay the asard are gone
we're asard give us our stuff
back I think it would make sense for
them to come to the milkway eventually
because they they came from
Ida Pegasus is the next stop and then
the one after that is is Milky Way good
repli well we had good replicators for a
little bit you know seen good
replication and then they and then they
commented out their good code and then
they went to
just the replicators is the only villain
I can think of that just shouldn't come
back someone turned a one into a
zero what if the gold old you know had
like um you know harnessed replicator
technology and built their own little
you know mechanical cocoons they could
crawl around the D Galaxy with instead
use
just before we move on to the next bit
then would you prefer you know I said
about how maybe we start with the gold
because then it gives us somewhere to
build from or would you actually urge
just something new just you know a vote
yeah or name just do you want something
new I I think you can do new things with
the
GU if you think so look at the how the
GU were when they were in power it was
all very disorganized it was lots of
infighting of Civil War
they had they had done that for
thousands of years and It ultimately led
to their defeat because because they're
just idiots they're gonna learn from
that mistake and they're going to be a
little bit more clever because they're
not
idiots it's it's it's just that they
they they didn't like sharing power but
maybe they'll get together and actually
do something and they'll be probably
more like the
mafia you know I I think Matt's on to
something you could probably have a
whole spin-off just a you know
alternative
gold uh story lines you know that does I
mean you know what if there was a system
Lord that went to Andromeda or some
other
Galaxy you know started all over and you
could have a whole I mean there's no SGC
there's I mean there's probably Gates or
something in there but it could just be
the gold olds uh you know War like I
mean it could be the Game of Thrones but
we just go
olds the game of
Golds yeah Golds of Thrones people
but I think yeah I like mat
idea I think so and and and then we can
throw in new things or we could throw in
something where the goal world end up
allowing a new enemy to come in with
something they doing or you know there
there's lots of I just think it's just
because it's the old enemy if it's
logical and if it makes sense and they
do something interesting with it cool
and it gives them something to build up
from you know as long as they're not
system Lords okay Bob's comments wheel
of
snakes oh yeah that would just yeah the
wheel of snakes I love that that just be
hon there he is I couldn't find
it Bob does do the most random but
brilliant comments thank you Bob wheel
of
snakes Jesus that's
brilliant burnings were the secret
leaders of the system law
that's bit of a soap opera twist though
isn't it at the end of the
episode really we are the
fings we are the fings my friend end of
episode to the end we are the
fings never mind
[Music]
we've for the video you do you w to sing
it stormy
because
um right the political situation on
Earth first of
all is the Stargate known is the secret
out well well real quick before we move
past new people and stuff do you think
that now that the power vacuum is gone
that other like like the ru were a
species we only saw once and they were
trying to hide from everything because
the gold were out more space wheeles
than marrier um we need three different
races of space Wheels just flying around
doing their thing uh but no no
um like the ru like these other kind of
like these species that are maybe hiding
from the ghoul they understand that this
giant evil threat's out there they
realize it's now gone would we have
other species start to kind of pop out
of the Woodworks and and introduce
themselves to the T to the jafa nation
to all these different people and would
that possibly bring yeah new threats new
stability new alliances so on so forth
kind of
make sense's he's been so nice and given
us you know a combination what a gold
pre we were talking about prequels
potentially in this fiveyear plan that
that MGM suggested and we said maybe an
ancients prequel would be very cool
would a go prequel could a go prequel
work I think both of those would be
really cool but we shouldn't do either
one because we've seen enough of their
backstories already and it would it
would lean into overe explanation and it
might screw up story down the road
focusing on one focusing on very
particular events in the GU world
history you could have a very good
series like the Anubis storyline back
before he was the system Lord like I
would like to see that flashed out I
magnet that we talked about another
episodes where there is no anub magnet J
the Anubis magnet um yeah because I I
could see that though because what we
were talking about was prequel series
that then give us in you know that the
the ad depth to whatever the overarching
story is so ancients that come but gold
W yeah they were the biggest they were
the biggest bad guy in the universe for
in the Galaxy thousands of
years you've got you've got so many
different system Lords like if you in in
Canon that we haven't actually seen so
like apep but then you've got um
a load a load of them
right see their rise to power and then
see like Anubis take over and then see
why raah banished
him I'd love to see PR ra getting sorry
yeah anuba is getting banished I love
the idea that it's how much of a dick do
you have to be for the system Lords to
think you're too
evil a massive he he then made the
system Lords think he was dead after
that 300E battle so you could then you
could then because we as an audience
know he's not dead and he's going to
come back so we could see him planning
and plotting and like going to KB to
like trick omala and like there's so
much story
there
yeah I know I said No at first but maybe
an origin story on the Unis home planet
and just remake it in like but just do
2001 but with a G and unas on the unus
home world and then finally leaving got
we got him on the hook there Mt we got
him we got him we reel him in he's he he
said no he poo pooed the idea but we got
him and no I think it's a brilliant
again if it adds to if it's done for a
reason there's a there's a vast history
Stargate I I hate prequels I hate them I
hate them I hate them but Stargate is is
begging for a couple I think because
there's so many things that they just
they touched on but they never really
explored in any way that could be
awesome I think if they were to do all
that it'd be nice to see it done as
meticulously and like well put together
as Old Republic stuff for Star Wars was
not like the high Republic is nowadays
but Old Republic mostly video games so
you probably wouldn't be familiar but
it's it's very it's almost more rich and
lore if not like way more rich and lore
than what the modern Star Wars is which
is great did they did they ever mention
in sg1 how many gates how many gate
addresses were
inactive because I'm wondering you know
there may have been a lot of
civilizations that you know did like
Earth buried their gate but then over
thousands of years they Rose in
technology they became space
Fairing and you know there could be
still out there I mean the universe is
real I mean even the Milky Way is just
vast and the gate Network didn't go
everywhere what if there's all these
civilizations that oh the Gold's gone
maybe it's safe for us to bury our gate
or you know to to see who what else is
out there you know maybe they could have
been using their space travel to e drop
on what's really going on you know
sophisticated
uh pretty quickly if someone did un bury
their gate because car wrote that
program didn't she to Ping to Ping gate
oh yeah that's right yes yes yes yes yes
that's right and then there was an
episode I think someone someone's gate
got unburied and then and then they sent
them out through and then I I can't
remember the episode name so it could be
two factions two countries or whatever
and and the Stargate was like a mythical
thing
and Country in the country where they
discovered it they were like yeah it
doesn't exist and they were right and
we've been fighting for so
long they
just I think that could definitely
happen yeah but they'll they'll know
pretty quickly unless they've turned
that program
off I mean Harris little argument in the
private chat because he's stupid little
boy stupid boy he's turned my perfectly
good joke against me bastard
and these things are
fun we'll discuss that at the end right
so um political situation on Earth um is
the Stargate still a
secret first of all this yes or no is
the starget still a secret har me no
Harris yeah yes I want to say yes as
well
honestly I want to
see I really want to see that the reason
I'm saying I hope no I hope people know
based on the presidencies and like the
political climate it was but I can see
the political climate shifting to to a
point
where we are no longer necessarily in it
for the good reasons like the the ORD
has come down from from the top and
we're doing things that are a little bit
different a little bit
more I don't know what the word is but
not we're not the the the B benevolent
guys we we used to
be the people in charge who put that
order I don't think would ever want to
reveal
the it's probably lining their pockets
they've probably got deals with planets
and stuff then they're making money from
the Stargate program true I tell you
what change slightly question change the
question slightly is it more interesting
for the TV show if it's still a
secret I think it's I think it's more
it's more dramatic if it's not a secret
because you know some point in time
someone in the Ia is going to open their
mouth you know and um or somebody or you
know the furlings will land on the south
lawn of the White House or you know AC
cross the street from Buckingham Palace
or something and how are you going to
explain that you know I'm still do you
do you think that maybe that can happen
and then still not say hey we have this
portal that can literally go just about
anywhere in the universe just by dialing
the right dial numbers and they say well
guess what we've actually Advanced more
than you thought we have in the last 20
years we have spaceships and just say
hey we're a space fearing CI
Civilization now and not so much we have
a Stargate maybe kind of keep that bit
out of it uh because if any Planet were
to accept that it would be the T you
know you mean just talk about our
spaceships and not the gate yeah just
say hey we got spaceships we're out in
space now look what we've been testing
for the last 15 20 years howy Andrew
well they could do that and they could
they don't have to necessarily attribute
it to the gate because we've already
have um like the Roswell crash in the
60s like so many like crash sites like
in real life that people already assume
we're building spaceships from they
could just use those plausible plausible
deniability is that what it
was plausible deniability an event that
is already in the in the public like
psyche they just attributed to that so
the one thing that I think that might
just well there's a lot of things but
the the one thing that's coming to mind
at the moment uh that would be just a
little bit of a caveat just for the
question again there's probably a half a
dozen caveats for the question
but if we have alphasight a and
alphasight b and all these different
places and we have 20 30 years worth of
human beings on these planets there's a
good chance a lot of them have kids now
and they're all on those planets are we
a multiplanetary species just with with
earthlings alone not necessarily other I
mean it's kind of like what we did
originally or what the ghoul did with us
originally but we're doing ourselves in
a way I think once we contact with those
in a public way I think as soon as you
open as soon as humans on their own
opened alpha alpha site a first I me the
alph site first one then I think we are
we may you know most of humanity may not
know about it but that's something we
did on our own not because we were uh
you know cattle to some other you know
alien species we did it all
still that but Arnold G just said otherw
worlds dot dot dot hybrids dot dot in
the in the chat oh my God like if if
we're on Mars for 100 years as a species
we develop chicken legs we start looking
a little different you know so the
expans is a little bad in that they
should make it a little more accurate
than that but like we would start
changing physi our physiology would
change in these different places could
they
add there's a series of books that
speaks with Arnold's uh
idea about hybrids and what Harris was
saying it's called a called the Mars
Trilogy red Mars blue Mars and green
Mars by Kim s Robinson excellent series
and he talks about the speciation of
human humans on different planets and
how that changes brilliant brilliant
great books no yeah okay I like the idea
of them having colonies where people
live but I just don't I don't know if
they would have done that yet because
every single planet they they've that
we've got bases on is is for science and
research that's true or for military
they've never
had um at least in
Canon um other than the Atlantis
Expedition where they did move out
essentially U they never
had let's colonize this planet because
there's never been a need to we've got
plenty of space on this planet there's
not been like a catastrophic event or
like a catalyst for angang on maybe we
should you know call and I somewhere
else just in case like that's never come
up a colony like that was uh Atlanta
true yeah yeah that's that's the only
difference but they didn't yeah yeah
that's the only that's the only
exception I can set of colies is going
to be to my that was more of an
expedition quad or something necessarily
a colony because they they they they
planned on returning so they didn't
actually fully move out they planned on
returning at some point yeah whereas as
a colony never plans on returning yeah
and it will be for resources when we
start but what what we would do probably
is subjugate nicely subjugate you know
like you work for us now you don't have
a flag here's a flag you now you we now
own you and to to m n and stuff like
that um that that's what we would and at
the end of the day we would do that and
because we've done it before and we'll
just give people pretty mirrors and
things like that and go oh look
reflection and then um dig all that for
us now and but that makes us know better
than the
gold You could argue well I like I I
mean I like us of course being the
protagonist and all that kind of stuff
like oh happy earthlings would might not
be perfect but we're trying to do good
generally but hell maybe we have kind of
changed our tune of the Galaxy a
bit it might it might be more
interesting to take us down that an
anti-hero or anti villain kind of Route
maybe I don't know do you have
oil well we'll have a bit of that please
Nadu would be the new oil um so
yeah like fossil fuels I mean Triton is
full of methane so you know and that's
in our backyard we're we're we're
talking about colonies and all that and
you know we got the two Brits up top and
the two americanos down here what if we
did a whole thing like we use Atlantis
to maybe power up a bunch of stuff and
yada yada but we want to find a way to
get back to Pegasus it might cost too
much energy we don't have enough
whatever to get back to um pegasus with
Atlantis or it would take a little time
whatever it's in the
dead yeah but I'm talking about like
bringing a colony of people kind of
there instead of like the way you would
be able to like populate Atlantis then
bring Atlantis back instead of doing
that would we be able would maybe if we
were not so good anymore we said hey
y'all piss us off at a certain point
those other people that had the other
alterate Atlantis City could we go take
over that Civilization you're you're
basically saying we're Canna have the
Atlantis tea party
yeah hey history repe like somewhere you
guys are still but hurt about that yes
you wasted tea do you know I don't care
about you becoming independent you
wasted
tea what are you going to do next spill
of
beer more careful is is the the whole
the whole moral of the Boston Tea Party
is you lot need to be more careful um
sometimes the very young do not always
do as they're told oh oh my Lord shot
fired hey if if the US ends up being
Earth in that situation
I think we've won at the end of the
day because we got plenty us are in
charge we're all in trouble
so Stargate not real
life yeah um but yeah um sorry sorry I
just saw
this yeah America's AR gonna get
that I'm guessing has something to do
about tle te T is that come from a
commercial I may have seen yeah tle
bunch of monkeys selling tea to people
it's it's the worst tea ever it's the
worst tea ever like most known yeah I
can't think is what I tend to drink so
tley tea is y'all's faster as beer yeah
kind of car we have Carlin beer which is
even more piss likee than
um Fosters I I actually have two cans of
Fosters in my fridge that I got from
when I left my previous job like a year
and a half ago they gave me a CR you
this mon
well I don't like Fosters I have told
you this before it's still in my fridge
and in a year's time it will still be in
my fridge yeah yeah
yeah saying sell you know you get those
you know those new machines that do like
cold and you can pour a pint of ler and
it's um it chills it you get like the um
the small kegs right um the kegs cost
like 30 quid and you only get like 10
pints out of them but Aldi by me has
started selling kegs of beer Moretti and
Moretti is the nicest beer oh my God
it's nice it's like a Belgium L it's
beautiful um for like nine quid so I'm
like well babe I'm I'm tell wife I've
got to go and buy myself one of those
beer pour machines now because it would
be wrong not to because I can get the
cake from Ali for nine quid think about
the money I'm saving by you know getting
my my beer pouring machine she hasn't
gone for it but um but I yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah she'll go for it I'll just
turn up with one look what I've got um
anyway just just use a Sidetrack money
to buy it you can't say no to that I use
that excuse a
lot why did you just buy that uh
Sidetrack
Money YouTube why I always say YouTube
Money YouTube money
um in your marriage not not that
much you told me how much money you made
last month so stop talking
[Music]
[__] um yes so what is mayborn doing now
Laura say Laura just said in the chat
what do you guys think mayor is doing
now mayborn not
mayoring is on a mayborne has gone to
like some Hawaiian island he's sitting
there with a beer and he's waiting for a
phone call he's just waiting for a phone
call oh nah we were talking about that
Atlantean ship becoming a colony ship we
don't need a colony ship if we got
mayborne you know damn well that dude
just made his own colony on some Planet
somewhere he's like you know what we
don't have enough
people I can make a few more I think
that's what mayborne did start a cult
somewhere did he already start a cult
yeah quite a cult but yeah he that man
looks like somebody that is only one bad
decision away from starting a cult oh
Arnold just said he's traveling with the
Lucian Alliance in the chat that would
be interesting give them a little tar
I mean he was the N so Lucian Alliance
isn't that far of a stretch to be honest
it's really not no I I think that makes
100% that we were talking about with the
Lucian Alliance is the gold really
behind the Lucian Alliance we said that
kind of makes sense maybe mayborn is
actually behind the mus lines Mak sense
well you know maybe mayor's middle name
is
Lucius that's where they got it from oh
my God
head um yeah Sam car just going through
some Old Mission briefings reading the
notes and he goes hang on
Harry Dam
it Dam it
may um what was the lines she said to
him you're an idiot every damn day of
the week yeah and ah the jokes on you
Sam I have an alliance I have my very
own Alliance
um on Earth then with the you know the
different things going on on Earth we've
got gold wal on Earth we've got the ni
we've got the ioa sorry um we've got all
these different things going on
um and and obviously I mean Brad wght
was very clever that he showed that
though we Humanity has a dark side yes
the SGC tried to do the good things but
the different the ID and things Tred to
do and the Align you know try to do
naughty things
um would whoever's in charge or would
whether the T be a positive or negative
influence in the Galaxy basically just
just depend on which president's
in at the time yeah that's why that's
what I was saying before the political
climate was probably shifted at some
point and and if it Hason want is what
we what's going to happen is it a US
president still doing it or is it more
like UN based or doing some secret world
government or something or like if it's
a coalition of governments that's worse
than just one person in charge because
you've got a lot of infighting there and
there's gon to be a president of the of
the of the like United Nations kind of
thing isn't that there's going to be
like one guy who who you like a
democracy in in some sort of way but
yeah one one very vocal guy there going
to be like a Vladimir Putin sat there
and he's going to like well if you don't
if you don't agree with me I'm not going
to give you
oil yeah and the UN is basically a sock
puppet for the United States is the
United States got one hand right up the
ass of the UN going oh yeah let's be
peaceful and it's completely the UN is
virtually redundant so if it is that but
at the end of the day the Americans have
got the Stargate so that puts them in in
charge anyway doesn't it I mean you guys
are Americans you you know better than
we do how the American political system
works yeah we ain't given that thing up
but we would probably be willing to talk
to people that might be but we're gonna
have control over the star that's for
damn sure but we the only reason we're
talking to people see what kind of [__]
they got that we can
take you know all of a sudden oh yeah
lithium they've got lithium oh they're
terrorists [__] are all terrorists
and they're holding their lithium over
our heads they're gon attack
Li we like them but you lithium guys if
if we were going to have colonies on
other planets it could be different
countries wanting to expand out so they
could start their own program on
different planets and
that's the Russians no long have a gate
because we sto we rented it from them
but we're not going to give it back like
obviously it's like it's ours now yeah
um what if they're just like well you're
not going to give this back
realistically how about we just go to
another planet we set up a a colon
Colony then we can go do whatever we
want
have our own G that makes that makes so
much sense and we were talking about
International versions of the show a
couple months
back perfect you know like here you go
here's a planet that's very Russia like
in the Russians here this is a planet
that's very
um Nigeria like send somebody there this
is one very India like send them there
so on so forth kind of deal this one's
very much like Canada the Canadian
program would be very polite the British
program would be very polite but we'll
still take shaky stuff um and uh and
then we just get drunk we going holiday
to other people programs to get drunk
and start fighting the British version
would just be full of museums full of
all the technology that we've just
stolen off
everyone here here's something that the
Russians could do they could go well we
want our own Planet okay sure fine they
go they have their own gate they find
another planet with another gate and
then they use that gate to dial into
Earth 247 to keep our gate blocked
that's what the Russians would do then
Seal Seal Earth forever from everybody
else and then sell us gas then sell us
gas which is what they always do space
gas now they'd probably find all the all
the NAA and start selling us NAA and
then say and like I goes oh no we're not
going to turn off the NAA oh there's
been a terrorist thing and then all the
Na's been turned off that's what they
did with the gas damn
them right so M has been turned off yeah
we just turned the Mac
[Music]
offical
or you could really screw over and turn
it into aqu quadria and just let the
planet go the Wayside you know over a
little bit of
time just supercharging planets just to
[__] with
people because you know sticking a rod
in the ground and sticking a zpm next to
it it's G we'll leave that for a couple
of minutes to see what happens the
quadria is just
diesel we think it's brilliant for five
minutes until you find out the vog
swagon have been lying about how it
works and uh never mind um right so
let's let's bring it all to a conclusion
because we've run over already and we
haven't even given um stormy chance to
um uh waffle yeah about what he's when I
say I want to go and then he'll come in
with something fascinating at the end to
ruin us for five 10 minutes it's always
that fascinating thing at the end get
yeah he's
thinking FC Bor too many shower thoughts
yeah um you should stop taking showers
sto
me I can't do that to humanity man you
don't want that he's in New Mexico you
don't want anybody in New Mexico not
taking
showers all the radioactive dust do you
ever have like what you think is a
brilliant idea at night you know when
you can't sleep oh my God that's the
best idea ever I must remember this idea
and then the next morning you go that
idea was stupid that's the stupidest
thing all that idea I thought was
brilliant last night when I was half
asleep is actually just the plot from
2001 Space Odyssey what is wrong with
you brain there's a psychological reason
for that I read about and your brain
basically just agrees with everything
you're thinking so you shut up and go to
sleep a goodidea yes it is good to sleep
that's that's that's so my I have
basically my wife in my head because
that's what she does as well yes it's a
good idea shut up and go to sleep that's
exactly when when when your brain's
actually rested in the morning it goes
that was
[__] really [__] and my wife does that
as
well so my subconscious is named
K right um Sarah don't don't don't say
things like
that it just it just gets him going it
just gets him going
um also don't say you're right stormmy
because that just oh that's just egging
me on bro that's just egging me
on that's an interesting idea stormmy
yeah always goes wrong but anyway how do
we bring this together what what are the
relationships like in the Galaxy then
are we all going to be like the UN or
Rosie or are they going to be conflicts
or are they gonna be whatever what you
think there's always gonna be
conflicts the milk away is so big that
even if the powers that we know about
are are all happy and and sitting in a
in a tree like singing kumbai like
there's gonna be just to be like scre
you
guys I wouldn't mind whatever we pick up
in we come back in like a part of time
where there are conflicts everywhere
small conflicts within the toer the
ghoul the Lucian Alliance us the jafa
the Lucian Alliance these this there
bringing in some Pegasus people maybe
all that kind of stuff and maybe that's
what if if we get a series or maybe the
movie might be setting something up like
that whatever order they want to go it'd
be nice for that series maybe to end
with all these small conflicts coming
together to a head and then setting us
up for what we want to see like way in
the future that way we get what we need
to get coming back to the series after
being gone for so long there is
something like okay like we're we're at
a boiling point is where we're starting
off it's interesting immediately jumping
onto things and then it has that uh that
fuse to to kind of wait till until that
Dynamite
explodes my metaphors make
sense stop listening go no I didn't no
no yeah 100% yeah g what you
think well I think it has to be a little
bit mix of uh you know exploration
Discovery wonder and
conflict because that's worked so well
you know for the franchise so far I
think you know it's uh and that's a very
I think a very human kind of story Story
I mean Mo most of our best stories are
always something like that you know and
um
hundm said the the UN will be required
in the Galaxy I'm wonder if that's the
ioa will the U because it's you know the
un's a puppet of the United States as
you said I'm wondering if the ioa which
is more much more or less a puppet of
the United States I'm wondering if they
would take on that role
galactically it would definitely be in
the conversation would they
yeah they would have to be I mean
they've been in on it since almost the
beginning and they've actually the Ia
has been control of
U well I I I guess that that was they
were controlling at the very end uh not
not Destiny but
atlantas no one's in control of Destiny
as far as I could tell
yeah yeah well you do have there is the
Ia person on Destiny what's name
um in in in Star Wars camil Ray um
yeah always trying to take over there we
go yeah yeah
cool they've got their their fingers in
a lot of pies I think yeah they're
definitely going to
be but I think we shouldn't discount you
know the um the Ia and especially the um
niid and the trust again you know we
have all these other um cultures in the
Milky Way who's to say that they have
not um already discovered some of these
other cultures that exist and are doing
their best to subvert them for their own
power and trying to control them before
Earth can really have at it or what if
they're working in um opposition to
Earth's special interest already I mean
look I mean the niid and the trust we've
shown or they the the series has shown
that they'll do anything and they have
no Scruples whatsoever and what if we're
already in a cold war Earth versus some
other culture that we don't even know
about we PR to sorry president kingy
that um in the head of it all said to
Kinsey Kinsey I just head of it all just
messing everything up for everybody yeah
boom sorry y there a bit of a long
weekend um are we covered it we
good happy I think pretty much described
what the universe looks like if Amazon
are listening you're welcome yeah you're
welcome very welcome if anybody sat in
Amazon going how should we do this I'm
just like we've explained it several
times really it's not complicated start
out with Daniel Jackson's original
lecture I will take if you use any of my
ideas I'll take a 5% cut I think that's
fair I'll take take a three and a yeah
I'll take a 0.1% and a credit a writing
credit that'd be cool I want I do want
an executive producer R whenever new
Prock comes on I sidre should take I
think 18.2% of the credit when Star Trek
comes back when Stargate comes back
sorry um if y'all need line producers we
will be there every day and helping
y'all just saying yeah we got you so and
and and I'm just saying that you know
Amazon can thank us I just you're
welcome Amazon you're welcome we've been
doing all the work for you've been
advertising it like crazy but guys thank
you so much um well we're on anybody
watched anything good we'll end the um
end the videos we normally do with
chatting about side Che
production uh let's see I've uh I
finished up The Walking Dead I finally
watched the last episode of The Walking
Dead and I did not understand the last
five minutes Matt I don't know if you've
seen the last episode
or it's it was just just like it came
out of nowhere and then it did some
things and said some
stuff and it was new foot a lot of it
was new footage and it's like what what
were they possibly setting up I mean I
so if anyone in chat knows what that was
about well they're setting up dead City
the three movies and then Daryl Dixon
too right I haven't seen it I'm just
maybe I don't haven't seen those maybe
but there were some confusing part and I
don't want to do spoiler isation here
but it was just some I just maybe I
missed something but I just didn't get
the last five minutes it was wonderful
to
see but you
know anyway you got lost you got lost
all dream
yes to watch that series I just think
zombies are the the most useless monster
story because I mean give me a rifle and
enough ammunition and I will sort the
zombie problem out pretty quickly yeah
but it's not it's not so a singular
zombie is not a problem a horde of
zombies very much is and civilization
Falls there's only so many bullets left
yeah I mean that's the thing is it you
gota and you you don't know if how many
people have been infected by the time
you know there's a problem I suppose
it's just I don't know just bored me
never everyone is infected everything
that everyone's infected becomes a zie
when you die you become one that's part
of the the okay everybody has the virus
well that's
unfortunate yeah that's just like [__]
is that is that the big reveal at some
point through the series then that they
realized that oh yeah uh I think it's
early
on they make it to the to the CDC in
Atlanta Georgia where they keep all the
and that was the what the last remaining
survivor of the CDC whispered into Rick
grimes's ear said you know we all have
it no because they didn't find that out
till Shane passed in season two in the P
penultimate episode yeah but but that
was confirmation is when he told Rick
that everybody has
it I thought he
said the CDC guy whispered it in Rick's
ear we we didn't know what he' said
until Shane died turned into a zombie
okay okay okay because he was never
bitten but he died and then he turned
and then and then it was like a
flashback kind of thing CA and also Rick
and Shane there're at this gate
someplace to this um this other facility
and they said you know I don't see any
bike marks on them that was the first
time his question I think that was prec
CDC maybe or maybe Rick knew about it
and just didn't say anything I'm not
sure and I suppose people aren't dying
many people are dying in natural causes
at this by that point so you wouldn't
realize straight away
there's loads of people that have
obviously like seen the world is is
ending and they've hung themselves like
on trees and stuff and they've just
turned into zombies and they just
say yeah just been there for like years
old folks homes just turn yeah yeah or
or like maternity WS where the woman is
giving a birth to a a dead baby the dead
baby starts eating its way
out although there's no teeth unless
he's got like one and did they show that
sometime is well that was the that was
the worry when Judith was born what if
she's born still born that's right
okay Christ yeah the first few seasons
are excellent I I I really good first
season but I will fight for The Walking
Dead Season one over the last of us
season one any day of the week the and
so now I'm like uh season five or six of
uh Fear The Walking Dead then I'm want
to move on to dead City and Daryl Dixon
and
I'm there's only one more season left of
U of fear of The Walking Dead I'm not
watching it don't like it I watched the
first season got bored me
too but I did enjoy the first episode of
monik I'm gonna watch the second episode
in the morning it was very good I
enjoyed it and apple have done it again
and and uh I don't know don't know what
the budget is for Monica I meant to look
it up $13 million per episode and the
entire budget for God Zilla minus one is
$15
million wow $13 million but you can see
that that I did wonder if they might
have spent a bit of money on that for
Kurt Russell and stuff expensive well I
I might have to Devil's Advocate you
just a little bit that first episode was
boring as hell and could have been done
in about five and a half to seven
minutes of screen time and I think the
second episode has really picked up a
lot uh they're setting up a lot in the
first episode to be
there's a lot to set up in their defense
if you are writing a um we get moaned at
on this channel sometimes we go oh
you're repeating yourself again you're
repeating yourself again I'm like yes
because one I have to consider the
stupid I'm joking and but no you have to
sometimes the thing is um I I do have to
be repetitive sometimes because also I
have to have in mind somebody might not
have ever seen a sidrick video before so
I have to tell a story it has to be a
story TV shows they have to it has to be
done in a structured way and also have
to start study and build up or people
moan or people that the other moan is
that you know it's like um
well that was my argument with Gen V
that new that that serus or gen Z
whatever [__] it's called started up
here and then it then I was bored in the
second episode and I'm like set things
up there's a structure to these things
that need to
work um but I like the first episode I
will watch the second episode tomorrow
and if it's even better than the first
days oh way better way better there's
still plenty of set up but there's
there's things happening at the same
time which is
nice what is this side trick you speak
of what is it I don't know if you can
tell me I'd love to know if you can
aners on a postcard to um sre1
gmail.com uh how about you haris what
you've been watching me how much have
you been to the cinema and not done any
actual proper
work hippie a few times let me uh think
about what I saw um I I went to go see
Ballad of song birds and snakes on
Thursday and it was I I didn't have the
highest expectations in the world and I
came out really enjoying it I I like
that all three acts are very much their
own stories like and and they make it
kind of like part one part two part
three all that pops up on the screen so
you know it's like different things but
it's it's nice where they all coincide
with one another but each one is their
own story
just to get the elephant out of the room
yes the first time Rachel zler starts
singing my head
went but it fits
narratively and the second or third
songs that happen in the film that also
fit narratively are really good the
first
one but after that ah you
know
ouch likes our Channel very much I don't
think so you hear all the time what do
you mean I think wants to get banned for
my
channel well good luck that I've been
trying to get banned forever but it just
hasn't worked out I keep trying to ban
everybody but keep I went to go see wish
yester day the new Disney movie and it's
the epitome of a Disney movie it's not
all that great and it's not bad it's
just kind of it's it's pretty damn
decent uh and it it it
literally well I mean actually they're
doing pretty well but I agree she this
would be the last movie that does well I
think if she keeps up what she's keeping
up
uh uh but but wish wish was good it
literally ended with like a Disney 100
advertisement like that's literally the
last scene of the movie It's sorry to
give it away it's it doesn't really give
anything away but it's
like like it's it's it's very Disney at
the end um that being said first two
episodes of Monarch because of Marvel's
last week I went to watch uh Miss Marvel
with my neighbor this week and it was it
was fun it was decent uh a lot than
people have been saying a lot Iman
valani is nice I didn't love the first
or the last episode but the rest of it
just I could listen to her talk about
superheroes for 50 episodes of anything
um but I watched Bluey Samurai on
Netflix this week I finished it I
started it last week finished
it maybe one of my favorite things I've
watched in years loved it if you like
Samurai anything even I know you're not
a big anime person am but do it I like
anime when it's good but I I'm one of
those people that likes I like animation
when it's good but when it's like
anything when it's good good that's the
way to think about
it but but y'all would all like Bluey
Samurai was
boring and you like the first episode of
Monarch uh it's all thing animation I it
can be difficult sometimes because it
can
be
when it's done it can be quite slow
sometimes just because of like the the
realities of making anything animated is
it's horrendously expensive and quite
difficult so sometimes it can be a bit
then the dialogue can be quite slow in
some particularly in anime as well so
like I said when it's
not really
fun um the debate was not rigged Harris
just wasn't quick enough to get
in it was not rigged and but the next
argument um you can argue against
somebody else and you just need to be a
little bit more forceful with your
opinion
okay you're American you know how to do
that
[__] you have to talk over people and be
arrogant
and okay ghost in the shelle I love
ghost in the shelle that was really good
which is why it's been remade a million
times since yeah the original was really
good yeah anything good then remade a
million times first episode is a tad
slow but there's enough bad asery to
keep it going I think all three of you
would adore blueeye Samurai but like
Ruben just said in the chat if you're
gonna watch something animated it needs
to be scavengers reain if it's available
if not find that
VPN do it do it my internet provider
blocks me if I try to use a
VPN bastard how about you Matt before we
say good night is there anything good
and excited about anything coming up not
watched anything but I did watch that
children in need special for Doctor
Who came out destination scar it was
very good very charity night that we
have on the BBC that was on Friday is
that right so they've done a little I
didn't even know children needed
happened I honestly had no idea it was
had happened and then I just I saw this
clip here on YouTube yesterday yeah it
was brilliant brilliant it's got a
million views already like it's it's
good Dr Who is like it's coming back
next next Saturday
so it's next week isn't it and then we
got the Christmas special and then it's
into the new doctor isn't it right the
Christmas special will be where we see
the new doctor I don't I don't think
they're doing a Christmas special I
think they are I heard some I saw
something about it the Christmas
specials coming back so I'm guessing
it's this Christmas as opposed to
Christmas
2024 I know I know of the three the
three anniversary specials uh there was
a rumor for Christmas specials
definitely because I made a video on it
last year um because we assumed it was
going to happen last year and then it
didn't but I don't know if there is
Happy Days that's four episodes this
year
so I don't think it's a problem that I
hold a poll open until I win
um that way I mean that's what Trump
wanted to do so um oh so you are the Fox
News of sci-fi
oh
I'm pretty sure this gonna be a
Christmas
special hey I should say everybody
should go to matn special for Doctor Who
confirmed okay cool yeah I did totally
forget I went to go see Thanksgiving the
movie Thanksgiving the first 15 20
minutes I I were fun but were not
tonally consistent and then the slasher
does his first slash and kill and the
rest of the movie is so much fun it's so
much fun it's bomb it's gory it's
great I'm not a big fan of slasher movie
but when a slasher movie's done well
they are a lot of fun it's it's the guy
that directed it is and wrote it is Eli
Roth do you know him did you watch him
God Eli yeah beu that guy ah
yeah but but the the the other thing I
knew I was forgetting two things it was
that and then then I finally finished
Tulsa King I I watched it all on love
the Tulsa King s it was great I really
love the Tulsa King it's my f it might
be one of the favorite things I've
watched all year good except I I
binged binged what they do in the
shadows season five because it was
finally it finally appeared on um Disney
plus over here in the UK and um so you
finished season five already yeah oh
yeah good no messing around um trying to
get my kids to watch it it's just the
best
show always keep your ey the background
kids like trying to teach them how to
watch it most keep an eye in the
background um it's it's just theit I I
binged it I got nothing on Wednesday my
computer packed in it stopped charging
the battery died and um and I'm there
like on the phone to my boss going yeah
my computer's packed in there's nothing
I can do as I'm pressing
[Laughter]
play bye
what they do in the shadows Boom the
things you got to do to watch Gear mod
be turned
into what his what his bloodline doesn't
want him to be done I just love I just
it's the best show on it might be my
favorite show I think I'm on just start
again watch again Watch the movie and
then uh it's not as funny but Wellington
paranormal is like their cheeky New
Zealand like cheap version of it and
it's it is fun uh but you get what I was
saying last week how it kind of turns
the comedy on the head a little bit and
gets a little more serious at the end of
season five yeah which was kind of cool
though because it's still funny but it
was like dark humor versus just like
silly it's just it's just it's just my
favorite show yeah I'm trying to get my
kids to watch it I know I'm on my one ad
I love it it's just his sort of sense of
humor I've got him watching um Boston
Legal he thinks Boston Legal is just the
best show that's ever he think it's
brilliant I go to watch Castle then I
watch Boston league on I tried to get
him to watch Firefly and he watched it
but he didn't quite get it um so I think
he might not actually be my son probably
not genetic I have questions yeah yeah
he actually well I'll send you a
catheter and a DNA test for
Christmas yeah I might need it I need to
have a word with him anyway guys thank
you so so much uh next week I had an
idea for a video and I forgot what it
was but we are going to do another
debate video very soon where we're going
to
and I think the next debate will be Star
Wars the most overrated franchise ever
um
disuss who wants Star Trek the next week
no we're not doing Star Trek the next
week because Star Trek is the greatest
second greatest franchise in history
this show is
rigged we could do Star Wars versus Star
Trek which is the age old debate I mean
we've been having the debate of like um
I don't know would that just be like an
enjoyability debate instead of like the
Sci-Fi debate aspect no it would be
whatever however you want to frame it
but yeah you can't do it the Sci-Fi
because as Star Wars fans always cop out
it's not Science Fiction it's no it's
not it was never meant to
be so don't set it in space on
spaceships then why not gatekeeping Star
Trek people
gatekeeping what
speaking of spaceships everybody should
go watch Matt's video on Destiny he came
out it was really good I liked it cheers
it was really really good go show it
some love Sid trekers damn it yeah watch
sh on the Community page sh doing quite
well to be honest I upload it yesterday
it was my it was my most best performing
video I had ever had and then I had to
like delete it and re-upload it and I
was panicking all weekend but it's
literally within the last like two hours
hours it's like picking up so I'm quite
happy yeah you should go watch it I
don't Carris did you put it out anything
this week on M3 Cube music Mir whatever
the hell it was
yeah yeah we did a cinema scoop and then
I we did Saturday last week not
yesterday um and then schmo's done a
couple things schmook did on Mondays we
always do comic adaptations weekly so we
were talking Marvel's Loki Invincible
okay oh okay and Invincible season 3 or
season two episode three whatever the
hell it is watch was this under your
live tab maybe I missed it yeah yeah oh
okay live tab's most active oh there it
is Adam web trailer good or no okay Y
and then what Wednesday's live because I
was fascinating in it and at no point do
I randomly rant for ages and then forget
what I was saying halfway through at no
point does that happen does it end up
being entertaining one way or another oh
yeah because we then have a long
conversation about what I think I might
have been going with it
wait Wednesday was the one that was like
just was it just shy or just above two
hours right it was a long one two hours
yeah it was a long
one I said we're not going past two
hours and then 20 minutes later we're
not going past two and a half hours at
45 minutes we kind of looked at the
clock and we're like oh wait maybe we
should talk about what we came to talk
about that's right because we didn't
want talk about any of the trailers we
were what were we were in about what
were we uh I can't even remember but we
got to the last five because can we and
you were just like I I've really spent
quite a lot of time like planning this
episode can we talk about half of it
please we just like SP we said gonna to
go in like two minutes yeah we we're all
going in about minut but um but yeah it
was we didn't we just kept ranting and
we it was it was a fun video we we did
so yeah guys all the links for all the
videos are in the description and all
the L all the different channels go and
check out stormy's channel it's
phenomenal and just all these live um
sorry all radio chats and
things Harris does they're fine and Matt
does some brilliant videos that are
Stargate related that are you gotta
check out Master not necessarily all
Stargate no it's just it's my channel is
just anything I'm interested
in which isg and at the
moment walk the trifecta
I did find an old uh Vincent Price
interview that I've got up and it really
explains oh cool why uh radio dramas are
really so good and he was like it's just
go watch it is is really informative uh
old interview of his y um just 100 that
there is a company in Australia that are
desperately trying to do a new star
Farscape and Jim Henson Productions is
trying to do it the problem is um they
can't figure out who actually owns the
IP and I'm not joking really there's
basically a defun company that own me a
big chunk of the IP and they just can't
but Jim Hensen Brian Hensen basically
they're just trying to get money for it
but there is a there's been a bit of an
argument it might end up in court who
actually owns the IP but then it's just
funing it they're just trying to get
money but they have been trying for the
last two or three years to bring far
back
love the [__] out of it great Show
Arnold I play Daisy I've been playing
daisy every day for the last 12 months I
have two servers on
PS4 that I own oh my God
if if you're in the Sidetrack Discord
I'll link you to it if if you play PS4
he literally just said should add a game
section to Discord as you said that yeah
you know I kind of missed the Minecraft
server man I maybe I was the only person
in in there but I love the [__] out of
you were the only person
in I had so much [__] going on man it
was just insane I had zombie Ranch and
it was just cool as [__] oh well before
we head off um you know guys I give a
little bit of um of our monthly anything
we generate on YouTube on on YouTube to
charity this month we're giving it to a
kids charity the basically presents for
kids in hospital and stuff so that's
that's going um but in December I give
all of the money we make to charity so I
would really love you guys to let me
know if there's any Charities that are
particularly close to your heart
anything that you think really
desperately needs help at the moment
anything that thing um you can DM me
over at Facebook with any
suggestions
um put it on the Community page whatever
you want to do um I would love to get
some ideas I I don't want I would like
it to go somewhere that means something
to the community if that makes sense so
um I know um Ker's got one that I'm
actually got to give money to as well
this month but you know that's fine um
but any anything please just let me know
and we'll we'll we'll looking that but
yeah it's not the December money Sor
it's January you're not having the
December money that pays for Christmas
presents um the Jan all of the money we
generate in January goes to charity so I
just need to know which one we want to
donate to start the year off right damn
right I'm thinking that all the things
that I do that are evil basically get
balanced out a little bit January yeah
when I'm at the Pearly Gates I'm going
who who
January um gu but you murdered 12 people
January I gave money to charity I gave
Mone to PCC have you murdered these 12
people yet yeah oh these future murders
are we talking about a Minority Report
here and do we need the review Minority
Report I need to go my my dinner's ready
my message bye bye Matt and we're gonna
say goodbye anyway but bye bye
Matt bye um and and any uh purp Jay's
trip to kamakan that's happening anyway
and whether my wife likes it or not um I
mentioned this to my wife last week then
I'm going to San dieo ComiCon next year
and she actually said um as long as you
not go to Vegas I like
oh but me Harris really wants to go to
Vegas though it's only six hours from
San Diego I
[Music]
know live yeah exactly and I've got I've
got to go there because I've got to see
stormy so um and depending on where you
leave in California to go to stormmy you
have to go through Vegas so it's not my
fault it's easier to go to El Paso Texas
to see me than to go to Los Angeles and
then drive to Vegas just this here but
beo I'm a Texan and you don't need to be
in El Paso oh shut up is good
food don't ruin for me if my wife
suddenly comes up with the idea that I
don't actually have to go to Vegas I'm
going to kill you stormy I want to
go fly into Vegas and I I will have been
there for a few days by that time and
then I'll find a way to wander to the
airport to get you I do not want the
first time we meet to be after you've
spent two or three
days oh
yeah I think you come and meet me after
I've been in Vegas for two or three days
I've got the so my so that my chemical
blood can try to cat get up to something
like that you're used to
yeah it's a
tragedy um but guys thank you so much as
always always with absolute Legends um
and this one of the best videos we've
done in ages thank you and and this is
the we're pushing two hours which we
haven't done in ages because normally I
stop stormy yeah see see what they got
you yeah yeah yeah yeah um but brilliant
um we don't we don't know what to do
next week but we'll figure it out so
yeah say byebye everybody goodbye
everybody oh wait I didn't get to the
brand thing on the [__] page and I
never do
right see you
[Music]